[Music]
always
that's I can't Grow Up by award-winning
Indie Duo Tegan and Sarah that's how I
feel I can't grow up it's from the
latest album Cry Baby Tegan and Sarah
are identical twin sisters they've been
performing together for more than 25
years now selling more than a million
albums go you they're also authors of
two books about growing up so their
best-selling Memoir was called High
School it was adapted into a TV show now
they've got a new graphic novel it's
called Junior High it's based on their
early teenage years it includes learning
to play music they're changing
relationships as sisters their first
experiences discovering their queer
identities Tegan and Sarah we're happy
to say are here in the studio hello
Sarah hi hello Aunt Tegan hey Sarah has
a baby 11 months old babysit so that
would make you an aunt Tegan I think I'm
gonna go by Aunt TT I like that I think
that's Rose of the time I think it's
easy to say TT so hopefully the baby
will say my name first
wow
everything you need to know yeah let's
make sure teakin's the first one that
gets in college but but it is
interesting about Junior High because
you talk about you had a fractured
relationship as sisters discovering your
sexual identities at that time but most
people don't want to go back to Junior
High Tegan why did you all think that
this could be fun to do you know for
Sarah and I school was definitely tough
like we were musicians and we were sort
of unconventional we were very
alternative we had a really cool group
of friends we figured out we were queer
we figured out we could play music it
was a really important time in our lives
and we get along really well we still
are friends with our friends from that
time and so going back and and hashing
that all out again is actually kind of
fun for us but no one else needs to do
it I know it's a misery for everyone
else no one really likes yeah junior
high but the thing is it was so candid
because you there's a whole there's a
bit of a section about getting your
period for the first time I so resonated
with this so resonated with me because
my I got my period at 11. and I went to
my grandmother and she said you're a
woman now I'm like what does that mean
my mother was away and then she said we
can't talk about it we have to wait till
your mother comes home wow I know
exactly and you know when you first get
it you don't know what the hell is
happening to your body I remember you
guys did this write out loud and proud
in this book in the book in real life
in real life I did not tell my mom for
almost a year whoa I was so scared to
tell anybody I don't even think I told
Tegan you know I really did think it was
something I should keep a secret I
remember before it happened finding out
about it other girls were getting it and
being like maybe I won't get it like
lucky me so I don't know I I hope this
somewhat destigmatizes it like but this
is what you all do in the book you take
things that are very personal and you
really sort of lay it all out there
including at times you had a fractured
relationship with each other yeah yeah I
think twins aren't supposed to have
fractured religions are supposed to be
best friends yeah supposed to get along
and Sarah and I we yeah we had times
where we really at each other's throats
it's hard to be the exact same age going
through the exact same things you know
and we were really different when I got
my period I just announced it to the
whole household are going to karate
lessons that night and I'm like I gotta
get something going on before I get to
karate you know it just we were really
really different and that sometimes
really made us butt heads we still do we
fought in the airport on the way here
Tegan fought at me yesterday a video of
that
[Laughter]
um in this book you also have a
character named Avery yeah
she's a mean girl as we like to call it
that bullies your characters what was
bullying like as you experienced it when
you were in junior high you know it was
interesting because we modernized this
story for junior high and put it in
today's times we have cell phones access
to social media we grew up in the 1800s
sorry
and a great dad we did not have cell
phones thankfully or social media but
you know it was it was old school
conventional bullying it was you came to
school and kids were talking about you
behind your back or they you know you
found a note and it had some you know
gossip about you or someone would call
you up the night before and be like I'm
gonna beat you up when you get to school
the next day just lay in bed like I
can't remember waiting sitting yeah like
in bed and crying and my mom being like
you're not going to get beat up and like
you know like having an actual
conversations
yeah yeah my mom was like okay you just
you know you throw Bob and William yeah
but it was it was definitely hard to
like put that in we didn't want to like
um we don't want to point the fingers at
anybody we wanted to make it a story
that's still aspirational so yeah Avery
who's the bully in the book is still
lovable I think she's cute if you like
Mean Girls yeah uh so since we're
covering the full spectrum of trials and
tribulations in middle school we got to
talk about discovering your sexual
identity right what was that moment like
when I imagine all your classmates or
most of them anyway were boy crazy and
you are not well on one hand when you
like girls and you're a girl and you
sort of keep it under wraps you get to
hang out with the people you really like
the most you know I still got to hang
out with girls I had crushes but I kept
it under wraps in this book again as
Tegan said it's aspirational so these
characters get to explore their identity
a little bit Sarah has a crush on roshni
and it's you know and it's it's
consensual and it's it's reciprocal you
know like they both have a crush on each
other and that was did it happen at the
same time for both of you no we actually
we we wrote about this a lot when we
when we wrote our book High School I
could not believe that Tegan did not
know until like grade 12 that I think
I'm simpler than Sarah not deep is what
our therapist yeah I I just feel like I
was a little more just went with the
flow but it was hard like when we got
into junior high and it started to be
like okay this guy has a crush on you
there's a lot of social pressure yeah
sure yeah like it was just like oh this
guy has a crush on me I guess I'll date
him and it just it just the second you'd
start dating a boy for me anyway it's
like the clock would be like how long do
I have to date him before I can break up
with him without anyone being suspicious
Straight girls feel that way
you're right yeah but that's why this is
so important the book in your music is
so important because it's great
storytelling yeah and it's so relatable
to so many young women in particular
yeah Bravo you thank you therapy
sessions sound funny also can I go to
the next one
that's the next book you know Tegan and
Sarah we thank you do you mind if I hold
the book up no please Junior High goes
on sale today wherever you there it is
wherever you like to buy your books go
out and get it